[Musique]
il y a environ 36 heures le chef du MI 6
a été victime d'une tentative
d'assassinats
de directeur qui est la tête du
commandement j'en assume la charge
le moment ne pouvait être plus mal
choisi cette attaque s'inscrit dans une
machine de plus vaste ampleur retirez
vous de la
ou nous dévoilerons tout où avez-vous
obtenu ces documents certains douteront
de votre aptitude à gérer la situation
un jeune père de famille qui manque
d'expérience ne faites confiance à
personne
salut
Adam Lorens le plus jeune chef de
l'histoire du mysx la CIA pense qu'Adam
c'est compromis tu sais qu'il est pas
très judicieux qu'on se rencontre cas
franchement Adam tu n'as aucune idée des
choses que j'ai faites pour t'amener là
où tu es j'ai besoin de toi ma plus rien
à se dire cette histoire ne fait que
commencer à DAB
trouver cette agent double
et faites le nécessaire
[Musique]
la famille est en danger c'est parce
qu'Adam a forcément commis un affaire
suis suivi
prends à ma fille tu vas me le payer
faire ça j'en sais rien je crois pas un
traître moi de ce que tu dis
tu as trahi ton pays pour elle la
justice doit le punir pour tout ce qu'il
a fait
pas un âge en double
tu crois qu'on va s'en sortir on va tout
faire pour
[Musique]